Today is hair braiding day,
so let's get ready to go get some box braids.
This is my hair routine.
I wash my hair every two weeks with the shampoo
and then go in with this keratin treatment.
Let that sit in my hair for a few minutes,
rinse that out,
and then scrub my scalp before I go in with deep conditioner.
I like to make sure that my hair is just really,
really clean, but also hydrated.
And then I go in with a few other products
after I've gotten out the shower.
One of the things I hate doing is my hair.
I don't know what it is.
It hurts my arm.
It's not fun. So lucky offered to do my hair for me. And blow it all out.
People seem to think that I hate my curly hair
or that I want to be more white by doing this.
I don't. I used to have really,
really bad eczema on my scalp,
which caused me to lose a bunch of hair,
constantly be flaky.
So in order for me to feel confident,
I decided to chop it all off
and wear a style that would cover up the front of my hair.
Which is why I also haven't gotten braids in almost two years now,
because my scalp wouldn't have been able to handle it.
But now, being pregnant,
my eczema has not flared up in nine months,
which is great.
So I decided to get Some knotless braids for this baby's birth.
I just don't wanna be dealing with washing my hair or combing it out
or doing anything,
so I always get braids
or a different protective style before I go into labour
or go on holiday.
I wanted to leave out some hair in the front to give it a feathery,
light look, but I ended up not liking it
and decided to just braid them all the way down.
And 10 hours later we were done.
And yes, my butt hurt,
but it was totally worth it.